♪ ♪
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
JUST THIS WEEK, WE LEARNED THAT
PROSECUTORS ARE NEARING A
DECISION AS TO WHETHER THE
CHARGES OF McKAY.
BUT THAT DIDN'T STOP THEM FROM
HIRING HIM.
WHAT WE EXPECT COMING OUT
TOMORROW OR VERY SOON.
LINDSEY GRAHAM, SENATOR GOOD TO
SEE YOU.
FIRST, ON THE HIRING.
WASN'T HE FIRED?
>> WELL, I TOLD YOU BEFORE THAT
COMPARED TO THE COVERAGE CNN
GAVE THE MUELLER REPORT
I'VE GOT SOME GOOD FRIENDS AT
CNN WHO TRY TO BE GOOD
JOURNALISTS.
BUT HERE'S WHAT HAPPENS, SEAN.
CNN HAS JUST HIRED THE ALLEGED
ARCHITECT AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
HOW MUCH TIME AND ATTENTION DO
YOU THINK THEY ARE GOING TO GIVE
TO THE HARWARD         REPORT?
>> Sean: WE HAVE AND ARE
EXPECTING DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF
THIS TO ROLL OUT.
FIRST WILL BE THE COMEY REPORT.
I EXPECTED TO BE AROUND 65
PAGES.
SOME OF MY SOURCES ARE
SUGGESTING THAT IT WILL BE
PRETTY DEVASTATING.
IT WILL SAY THAT HE WAS NOT
CANDID WITH THE FBI.
LACK OF CANDOR.
THAT'S LINE.
THAT WOULD BE WHAT PAPADOPOULOS
GOT IN TROUBLE FOR.
I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IF WE
DON'T APPLY OUR LAWS EQUALLY.
THEN, THE NEXT WILL BE THE FISA
ABUSE ISSUE.
THAT WAS THE BULK OF INFORMATIO
INFORMATION, HILLARY'S BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN LIES.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS, HOW
DEVASTATED, YOU BELIEVE YOU SAY
THIS WILL BE DEVASTATING.
WALK US THROUGH WHAT YOU THINK
WILL HAPPEN.
>> WHAT I THINK YOU'VE GOT TO
SEE IS BASICALLY AN ATTEMPT TO
DEFRAUD THE FISA COURT.
THE DOSSIER IS NOT VERIFIED TO
THIS DAY WITHOUT THE
STEELE DOSSIER, THEY WOULD HAVE
NO WARRANT AGAINST CARTER PAGE.
I THINK YOU ARE GOING TO FIND
PRETTY EARLY ON THAT THERE WAS
NO PROOF THAT HE WAS WORKING FOR
THE RUSSIANS AND HAD NO CONTACT
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
I WANT TO REPEAT WHAT I SAID
EARLIER ON IN THE INTERVIEW.
CNN HAS JUST HIRED THE PERSON HE
IS INVESTIGATING FOR COMMUTING
CRIMES AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
CNN HAS JUST HIRED THE PERSON OR
CNN HAS JUST HIRED THE PERSON OH
CNN HAS JUST HIRED THE PERSON OE
IS INVESTIGATING.
IT'S REALLY A SHAME.
>> Sean: LET ME RUN THROUGH A
SERIES OF QUICK QUESTIONS.
IF I COMMITTED PREMEDITATED
FRAUD, DO YOU THINK I'D BE
INDICTED?
>> Lindsey: YOU ARE AN FBI
AGENT, AND YOU GAVE THE COURT
AND DOCUMENT YOU HAD NOT
VERIFIED AND YOU SAID IT WAS
VERIFIED, YOU'D BE IN REAL
TROUBLE.
OPENED UP THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: WHEN THE FBI FINALLY
GOT AROUND TO IT, THEY EVEN SAID
90 TO 100%.
>> Lindsey: TO THIS DAY, IT'S
UNVERIFIED.
THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION, THERE IS NO REAL
EVIDENCE TO SHOW THAT
PAPADOPOULOS WAS ACTUALLY
WORKING WITH THE RUSSIANS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, OBAMA, IF
ANYBODY ABOUT THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
AND FINALLY, WHY DID THEY NOT
TELL THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN THAT
THEY HAD CONCERNS ABOUT PEOPLE
WORKING FOR HIM, TIED TO RUSSIA
QUESTION BUT THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO.
>> Sean: DO YOU AGREE WITH
ANDY McCARTHY THAT ANY
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION HAS TO HAVE A
PRESIDENT BEHIND?
DOES THAT MEAN THAT BARACK OBAM
BARACK OBAMA, THE PRESIDENT AT
THE TIME, SHOULD BE ASKED WHAT
HE KNEW AND WHAT HE KNEW ABOUT
ALL THIS?
>> Lindsey: I CAN'T IMAGINE AN
INVESTIGATION OF THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINEE WAS NOT APPROVED AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL.
I CANNOT IMAGINE IT HAPPENING
WITHOUT SOMEBODY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE KNOWING ABOUT IT.
THE QUESTION FOR ME IS, WHO TOLD
OBAMA.
WHEN WE FIND OUT WHO THAT PERSON
IS, WE BEGAN TO PUT THE PUZZLE
TOGETHER.
>> Sean: YOU THINK YOU NEED TO
BE ASKED THOSE QUESTIONS, SIR,
UNDER OATH?
SEE FIVE I'M GOING           DID
SEE FIVE I'M GOING           DIY
SEE FIVE I'M GOING           DIU
SEE FIVE I'M GOING           DIN
SEE FIVE I'M GOING           DIO
SEE FIVE I'M GOING           DIM
PRESIDENT OBAMA ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION?
YES.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA THOUGHT ABOUT
THE INVESTIGATION WHY DIDN'T